that'll be relevant in just a couple
minutes I promise so hi everyone um I'm
Liv Ericksson i am a virtual and
augmented reality developer evangelist
from a little company you may have heard
of called microsoft if you want to be
inundated with more tweets about virtual
reality than you ever thought a single
human could produce this is my Twitter
account I love talking about VR just
about as much as this picture shows you
can probably guess I absolutely adore
immersive technologies and I'm really
really excited to be here with you today
to share this so I'm going to jump right
into it and start with the big question
why care about virtual reality and why
work on virtual reality I generally
wouldn't give this device to people I
get asked a lot what made you get into
VR AR and I was in the situation where I
made my entire life decision on what I
wanted to do with my career based off of
a YouTube video again not something I
generally recommend people do but I
moved out to the San Francisco Bay Area
three years ago and I wanted to find a
technology that I just wanted to spend
all my time doing and loved very
passionately and I saw a video where
someone was talking about the oculus
rift developer kit too and I was
immediately like yep that's it i'm going
to just drop everything that I have
learned up until this point and do VR so
y vr it's changing the way that we think
about computing and I'm gonna start with
this one it's really really fun I was in
the situation when I first got out of
college that I didn't have this passion
for what I was working on I had a great
team I was kind of like okay this is
cool but I never really made this
connection that what I should be working
on should just be really fun and I
really loved it and I needed to find
something in my life that I found really
fun and virtual reality was one of those
things having this ability to be
transported to an entirely new world
elevates storytelling and as humans we
like telling stories we like to relate
to each other through stories
having access to an unlimited number of
virtual places that basically I create
out of something that I think about and
like yeah you know what that sounds
really cool I want to do that it's
opening up this whole new world where we
can actually build anything that we
think of this is a picture from my very
first virtual reality experience that I
ever did I spent my entire life loving
Star Wars any other Star Wars fans in
the audience I pretty sure I can't be
the only one yeah yeah okay um so my
very first gr experience was living out
a dream that I had had since I was five
years old in getting to do a lightsaber
training demo that was the same thing
that Luke did when he got on to the
Millennium Falcon in the first movie and
that was really kind of eye-opening for
me was experiencing this technology and
realizing that it had the potential to
help me live out this kind of fantasy
world dream that I had never thought
would be something I could physically do
virtual reality is changing the way that
we relate to each other that talk on
empathy was absolutely amazing and it
really hits home a lot of these points
that we are constantly seeking out new
ways to relate to each other so this is
a picture from when I went and visited
my parents these are my parents they're
being featured prominently here I took
that with this camera that you just saw
me kind of hide behind the podium and
take earlier because there's my sister's
missing from this picture I went back
home to visit them but she wasn't able
to take off work and with kind of this
immersive technology that's developing
in this ecosystem I was able to take
this picture that I can stick into a
headset and it's like I can go back to
that place in time and I can remember
exactly where I was what that felt like
and I can have other people experience
that very specific part of my life
that's very important to me for all of
you I just took a picture standing on
stage behind the podium because I'm
nervous and I I know that when I talk to
people after I give talks you know some
of them are oh I would love to speak but
I don't know what it's like and we now
have the technology where you can see
exactly what it's like to be standing in
my footsteps right here on stage at this
very moment and in the future I get to
come back
and revisit that to which I find
fascinating and it's changing how we
relate to technology I love this picture
I love this picture for a lot of
different reasons but what I love about
it is that it really captures this idea
of thinking about robots in this case
but technology in general in new ways
that are more human they're more
personal we're able to start thinking
about devices and how they play into our
lives on a very new level that we
haven't quite had before you know almost
everyone in this room if not everyone
has a device that they're carrying
around that connects them to the people
they love the information that's
important to them and virtual reality
starts to elevate that when you can
stand inside rooms and interact with
data in ways that are more realistic
more like the world that we're used to
experiencing compared to more
traditional computing platforms vr has
benefits around fundamentally changing
that way that we interact with
technology so you'll see in a few
minutes an example of a demo that I've
built that takes Excel data and graphs
it in 3d for me I love technology but I
haven't really hard time looking and
remembering charts and being like okay I
know that was telling me something
important but what was that and when you
start to think about data in ways that
relate it back to what you're
experiencing something like the price of
something in stacks of dollar bills
becomes a lot more memorable than if you
simply saw a number and started to try
to remember what that meant because
we're spatial creatures we interact with
things in 3d all the time that's how our
world works as we know it so before we
even dive into the VR web I want to
start with this going over what the VR
ecosystem today looks like so first we
have probably the most common mobile VR
device type available and this is
powered by a smartphone it's a device
that is essentially allowing your server
or your your phone to serve as the
processor and display for a VR
a device have any of you do any of you
have a mobile VR device a few of you
good okay that's good that every time I
ask that question at a talk that number
goes up which makes me personally really
excited because I feel like I'm I'm
doing the right kind of talk for kind of
how the industry is growing and evolving
so mobile VR like i mentioned allows
your phone to serve as the primary
processor behind all of these
applications and the applications are
running are just generally simple
smartphone applications you have a
number of internal sensors that are
measuring rotation and head orientation
so it's tracking kind of where you're
moving feels very natural and updates
the screen accordingly but it tends to
be a less powerful or immersive
experience than what you're capable of
running in something like a desktop via
our device with desktop ER devices
you're generally running standard PC
applications your head mounted display
is entirely separate you're not powering
this from the device itself you're
powering it from an external computer
which generally means that you're
tethered in you still have a number of
those sensors that are measuring the
head tracking the orientation of your
head and where you're looking but you
also have a number of other potential
devices like seeing here you could have
hand tracked controllers you could have
full room scale tracking systems that
are watching where you're moving around
so if I move over here it'll know that
and you end up with a more powerful
experience but again at the expense that
you're tethered to a desktop lastly and
this is very very kind of like broadly
separating VR devices into these three
categories and this is changing almost
monthly now but if I went through and
listed everyone we'd go way past 30
minutes and there's a lot more
interesting stuff to talk about the last
one is standalone devices and these are
devices that are all in one everything
is contained in this case the headset in
the headset and the controller but also
sometimes just at a headset itself and
they can be mobile or desktop operating
system based they may be hybrid devices
in the example of this headset you can
actually take the controller away which
is where all of the processing is done
and plug it into a desktop so you have a
different model but what you're starting
to see here in the industry is that new
devices are coming out and playing and
pushing the boundaries of what's
possible with immersive technologies
today
and if you haven't had a chance to try
any of those find me tomorrow because
i'll have my gear vr with me and i'm
more than happy to do demos I love
showing people V our stuff for the first
time so why think about the browser as a
platform for virtual reality experiences
in the future right now we're still at a
relatively early stage for this wave of
VR it's come around a couple of times in
the past it never really landed but
we're starting to see this resurgence of
the technology because we finally are in
a position where we have developer
conferences like this to get developers
excited about building applications for
immersive technology we're a lot more
comfortable with technology and putting
stuff on our faces and running around
with goggles on and we haven't really
reached the point yet where there are
you know best practices that are defined
or set standards which makes it a really
fun and interesting time to just get in
and start experimenting so when you're
considering all of this the browser as a
platform for virtual reality becomes
really interesting a lot of the things
that make the browser a really good
option for a lot of applications today
are also paralleled when building for VR
you have the ability to build an app and
not have to think about what it's
running on that's a very very
generalized statement because of course
at this stage you have to think about
kind of what you're running on from a
design perspective and feature
implementation but the benefit of the
virtual reality web is that you can have
an application and start building out
that experience that will work
regardless of the device that you're
using it on or if you're even using a VR
device at all this is really good when
you're kind of starting out with vr
development because it allows you to
focus on the content rather than
learning kind of the ins and outs of one
particular platform because as I just
mentioned there's a huge number of those
and it's changing almost monthly at this
point you have open access to content
which is really critical for virtual
reality experiences because we haven't
really figured out how to define them
yet in a situation where you have maybe
a three minute experience in VR that
captures very specific content like one
maybe a festival experience is that a
nap
is that a smaller piece of consumable
content is that a news story and when
you are building these out to run
natively and you're going through an app
store you're at someone else's ability
to decide whether or not it's a game or
if it's an article and whether or not
it's a big enough scope to put on the
App Store so when you think about the
web as a content platform for virtual
reality you have a lot more flexibility
over that control and what experiences
you're able to distribute you're letting
the browser do a lot of the work will
get into the specifics about the web via
our API in just a second but at its core
looking at the browser as a VR platform
allows you to let the browser take care
of a lot of things that individual SDKs
would otherwise that you would have to
be implementing separately in your
application so one of these benefits is
that you are able to look at
cross-platform development and say I
don't even want to think about whether
or not I'm running on a desktop with an
oculus rift or a mobile phone with the
browser in a cardboard headset I just
want it to work and I want it to look
good if you're not running VR headsets
at all and you lastly which I like in
terms of developing for VR you get to
bring your favorite web technologies
with you it's JavaScript rendering all
of this in a WebGL context you can build
on top of your favorite sites your
favorite technologies you can add this
to things that already exist because of
that framework and those that potential
for adding that layer of 3d graphics
lets you really build some really cool
stuff with all of the things that
already exist in the JavaScript
ecosystem so when you start to look at
building the VR web the elements of
today's ecosystem you know it's not just
one specific platform one specific
framework though it does generally share
that core around the web view our API
however there's a lot of flexibility in
how you can start building virtual
reality web applications today so at the
very top level where you look at 3d
JavaScript libraries because these are
what's going to make up the majority of
what someone will see in your
application so one of the first
considerations is
how am I going to build this environment
what do I want people to be inside of
and experiencing when I'm building an
application JavaScript libraries like
3gs in Babylon provide these ecosystems
to build out 3d applications so that you
don't have to write a rate caster or
shaders yourself or even go through and
worry about writing and defining objects
and primitives these libraries kind of
take that off so you can think about
okay what is it exactly that I'm
building and how do I have those tools
to do that and both of these libraries
have support for web PR today so when we
look into the web view our API it's an
experimental API for browsers that
allows the browser to handle all of
those interactions with VR hardware so
it identifies corrected connected
peripherals that you may have so in the
case of say a vibe room scale system it
identifies you know that you are in a
room that's tracking VR and you as a
developer just kind of have access to
that you don't have to worry about you
know doing different checks of what type
of device and my running is it actually
connected at all is this a mobile phone
that's running in a headset the browser
does all of that and it then passes in
that display data so that a camera and
your scene can just update seamlessly
with whatever is happening on the device
and you don't have to worry about
interacting with the hardware right now
the webview our API is supported in
Firefox nightly in chromium with paths
to both of those browsers longer-term
under the hood in web be our API it
breaks down virtual reality devices into
different components so that you can
access the different parts of the
hardware some of the interfaces are
related specifically to rendering a vr
seen appropriately for different
headsets while others will handle things
like the orientation the expense ability
to provide additional services like with
gamepad or audio and for a desktop a VR
device you may see things that are
completely separate from the headset
itself like additional tracking cameras
or controllers for a mobile phone it may
just be kind of making up that this
exists and getting those capabilities to
provide the implementation itself so
under the hood you're looking at the
base of all vr devices which is a vr
display whether or not that's you know
all contained in one package or if it's
in a number of different devices the API
will recognize these devices and pass
those on and say hey
you have this plugged in you can use
this at the state of any at any given
time the state of the headset will be
saved in the VR pose so it will know the
difference if I'm looking here as
opposed forces if I'm looking there as a
different pose and all of that
transitional data in between gets handed
off to the application to use in in the
situation where you are say running a
full-scale VR experience you'll also
have the stage parameters which will
tell the browser application you have X
amount of space to move before you will
hit the boundaries of this and as I
mentioned extensions for a lot of other
interfaces are also provided and if
you're interested you can go right there
and then so when you look at the kind of
over arching libraries and developing
for web PR it reuses a lot of libraries
as i mentioned that regular 2d 2d
display 3d applications will use with
3gs babylon and there's a few libraries
that sit on top of that and essentially
will just pipe in a camera update and
provide all of the additional
functionality of having that headset on
the web via our framework contains three
major components for working with
browsers that have desktop headsets
plugged in and then a polyfill that
fills in all the rest when you're on a
mobile device so the VR controls apply
the headset transforms to a scene camera
the VR effect is going to calculate and
tell your application how it should
render your application depending on the
screen size the pixel density resolution
which changes from device to device
especially when you look at mobile VR
and then the web viewer manager handles
moving in and out of web PR and non web
PR mode which I'll show in just a second
but of course there's always more
there's actually a pretty rich ecosystem
being built on top of the web view our
libraries that make it even easier to
develop if you're just starting out for
virtual reality applications and these
are generally wrappers around the
JavaScript implementation of the web PR
API that you can use if you maybe prefer
markup style languages like a frame and
visual programming systems like visor
create these are options that are
available to let you kind of program
right in your browser
an experiment with different different
scenes different kind of technologies to
figure out what works best for your
specific experience and they they just
provide a couple of options because who
doesn't like options for development if
you are familiar with game programming
and game development there's also the
ability now with the Unity game engine
to build an application and export it
directly to a WebGL web VR seen this
lets you use JavaScript c-sharp boo to
write scripts in the Unity game engine
and you add in a plug-in that says I'm
going to export this to the web and I
want it to support VR and then all of
the desktop browsers that support what
VR will also let you do that in the
application and I'll have a video of
this in just a second because that's
enough talking you probably want to
start seeing this in action as a heads
up these are some videos that i have
taken from inside a VR headset so if
you're very very prone to motion
sickness it may get a little wobbly at
times on the screen just as a heads up
for that so the first thing that I'm
going to show you is a video of the
application that i was talking about
earlier and this is a way of taking a
traditional data set that you have and
looking at it in an entirely different
way so i'm going to go ahead and this
was shot on of mobile phone you can see
when i'm starting out it's just a
regular website you don't have to be in
VR mode for it and I'm going to go ahead
and see if I can play that there so this
is just using a bootstrap template to
kind of render everything because you
want to just be able to kind of have
those experiences that users are
familiar with and then it loads in a web
vr scene that's rendering this graph
that I took from the Excel data and
putting it into 3d when I switched it
into VR mode it starts rendering
stereoscopically side by side so that if
I was wearing this on my head it would
now be rendering appropriately for my
eyes and I can look around and I can see
this and it's a little bit hard to tell
on a video screen kind of cuz this
screen itself is very large but for me
being able to kind of stand inside of
this graph and see things like oh yeah
the cost of living in San Francisco is
very very
large and instead of having this kind of
arbitrary scale these are in units of me
like I'm standing there and I can look
up and see 700 Livi's standing there for
comparative kind of analysis of the cost
of living so this next sample that I
built here is using a frame which is as
I kind of rushed through a little bit
earlier there a markup styled language
from ma's VRS team where you can
essentially use markup to wrap around
three jas objects and create virtual
reality scenes this is a live link so if
we want to test out the conference Wi-Fi
here and you want to see for yourself
what this looks like on a mobile device
you can go there I as you can see love
my little 360 camera and I'm going to
actually go ahead and switch over to the
scene live so you can get a scene get a
sense of what it looks like on the
desktop browser but up here in the
corner you can see that's what it looks
like on a mobile phone very similar to
the application that I just showed you
because again it's using all of the same
underlying frameworks there but I've
built this scene out based on some
pictures that I've taken from this trip
already I've showed this before or rough
a rough kind of similar version of this
application but the cool thing about a
frame is that this takes 17 lines of
code this is the entire website that you
just saw excluding that one script
source so I'm cheating a little bit
there but if we go ahead over and switch
into the browser here I don't have a
desktop view our device plugged in
because I don't have a desktop with me
um and that's not showing so let me let
me switch that over real quick I
apologize if I break the projection
system for like all the other stuff so
you can see here that I've actually got
this scene that's showing a 360 video or
a picture that I took at the blue lagoon
on Tuesday so I can look around with
this since I'm not using a VR device I
can use my mouse to just kind of click
and drag and this renders the way it
would in any browser and it's not in VR
mode because the browser is detecting I
don't have anything plugged in if I did
I have this little button down here and
it's not
let me click on it because I don't have
a headset plugged in but if we switch
back over to the slides and i'll see if
i can get this you get a sneak preview
of the next slide here oh no let's see
well you know what I'll just keep well
so it happens when you try to show the
live demos but we'll just duplicate it
and you can go through the rest of my
slides with me
perfect all right and so you can see
that that's handling all of the code
that I didn't have like all of the the
webview are switching and everything
like that really powerful framework
there this video here is what i was
mentioning earlier with the export from
the unity engine into a web view our
site so i'm going to go ahead and just
click on this real quick to show you
that this is sitting in a WebGL canvas
and i recorded this from my desktop
using my oculus rift so I put this on
I'm looking around in my head set its
tracking all of that and passing that
into the WebGL contacts and I don't
really have to do anything specific to
say I wanted this to work on the browser
it's the similar export function that I
could have used if I was building it to
a desktop application but I was able to
just say I'm gonna stick this in a
website and go with it so I'm going to
switch back to this real quick because I
think that this kind of starts to show a
lot of where browser-based VR will make
the most sense kind of in the short term
and that's in that right now not
everybody does have a VR device you need
to start thinking about these
experiences in a very hybrid sort of way
which is hard to do if you're building
native applications for VR either
they're in the VR app or they're not but
when you start to think about the web as
a platform for VR you have a lot more
flexibility with how you're able to
build out these experiences to work in
that kind of hybrid model you know
sometimes we do have our phones and we
want to do you know we want to have that
flexibility of looking around with the
phone and put it put that in the headset
real quick you can imagine if you were
shopping for something online maybe new
furniture you wanted to say you know oh
that looks really cool but how big is it
really and you can put that headset on
super fast see the size of the furniture
the color of different apple and you
want to see what that color of the
dresses and you have that ability to
kind of look in this experience and be
navigating through and working with
stuff in a very seamless way so looking
ahead and thinking about kind of what
the future of VR in the browser looks
like these are all things that are
evolving really really rapidly over the
coming years as VR is becoming more and
more widely adopted
over 5 million cardboard units were
shipped in as of January this year and
that was what nine months ago almost and
the market is like regularly making
improvements new devices are being
announced support for browser-based VR
for these devices are being announced
just yesterday actually the open-source
VR headset and the developer kits have
released their support for the
browser-based VR and because of the way
the kind of virtual and augmented
reality are blending together even at
this early stage there are custom
browsers with in virtual reality
applications that are starting to add
support for holographic content so you
can almost have like a augmented or
mixed reality scene inside of a virtual
reality application based on web PR so
you can write a web view our site view
it in VR and then have that come to life
within another virtual environment you
start to get at a very inception level
kind of thing we're really at the
beginning like the potential with all of
the different smart and connected
devices we have around the internet of
things around biometric devices Big Data
machine learning starting to bring all
of the tools that the web has kind of
been evolving over the past several
decades into immersive content brings
with it a lot of capabilities and a lot
of potential for very very interesting
applications in the future of course
there are always challenges with things
like this bringing browser performance
with 3d content on par with native
applications and around framerate
latency it's a little bit of a challenge
but I've seen some really compelling
examples of people hitting 90 frames per
second and some of these experimental
browsers and custom builds of
development browsers so we're getting
there and it's definitely something
that's going to be feasible when you
start looking at different types of
applications and of course the content
that you're building is going to depend
a lot on the requirements for your
performance in the first example if
you're building an Excel chart you're
viewing an Excel chart without a lot of
heavy animations that's going to be a
lot different performance wise in the
browser than something like their full
3d 360 degree game that you're watching
or and playing with cross-platform
design experimentation as I met
right now a lot of the considerations
around building a web view our site come
less around technical decisions that you
may have to make but more around the
design considerations if you're wearing
a headset with a phone in it you're
going to have a different number of you
know interactions that are available to
you then if you're using something like
the vibe where you have a full room and
you have hand controllers and then
lastly getting really rich visual
editing tools in 3d at for building 3d
experiences in the browser is something
that is also again kind of being worked
on right now but it's at early stages
it's really challenging sometimes to
right things and knowing kind of what
the 3d coordinate system in the headsets
going to look like if I'm writing that
all in texts so if I know you know the
z-axis could be in front or behind me
where do I put things if I can't see
them relative to one another having
those visual editing tools makes a lot
of sense but we're starting to see more
and more opportunities where you don't
just have visual editing tools on the
monitor in front of you but you also get
them inside of a virtual application
yourself so you can sit there and code
and see these objects appearing next to
you as you're writing them so with that
I want everyone to go build something
awesome and there's so much that is out
there right now around the ecosystem if
you want to learn more I have a github
repository where I've been collecting
basically all of the resources I can
find about learning virtual reality
development in general design the
different options that you have I love
like I said tweeting and talking about
VR so if you have questions you can
tweet at me or you can you'll find me
I'll be around to the next two days love
to talk to you more about all of this
and with that I hope you're kind of
getting excited about immersive content
because right now you know the way that
we interact with a single screen or
multiple screens is fundamentally going
to be different how we interact when our
entire world and our entire environment
can be manipulated and changed and we
could have you know screens all over the
place or you know virtual things that
are sitting on stage to talk to you
about things and demoing things with you
so with that I want to thank you so much
for having me out here and I hope that
you enjoy the rest of your time